they're boarding us
if you're gonna see any movie on imax
you want to see a movie like this you
know it's huge scale action visual
effects are amazing no crow oh yeah this
one well if you're talking hi max I mean
he can't be great to see space & planets
on a big screen we will find hope in the
impossible I would recommend the largest
format because a lot of the shots the
detail the scope it's designed to be
seen on a big screen our captain will
come for us mercy will be the last thing
on his mind I am counting on it it's an
enormous thing you know it's good to see
it on screen that size because the
spectacle of the movie is very exciting
you know but at the same time you have a
film which has all the philosophy and
the thought of a star trek movie that's
what this doesn't get messy we're making
it to be seen on a you scream they're
the frontier of sound and visual
technology I think you're under
estimating you entity hi mags obviously
we gonna get a lot of bang for your buck
hold on to something
you